they've always shown a great deal of
respect for me as an actor and and I
I've been very thankful for the things
that they've done absolutely yes
absolutely yes next question yeah you
did
you did A Tiny Tim and Tiny Tim who did
not die oh isn't that swell we're right
here on the set folks this is the real
thing the scary thing is this bridge is
a character and Miss Piggy's real that's
right yeah that's very true a bigger
pardon how would the bookkeepers like to
be suddenly
he will wait
this is my Island in the Sun it's very
much like my own relationship with the
Muppets it's a guy who deals with uh
lots of weirdness and crazy things going
on you know and I get to get to sing a
couple of songs in it I've never sung
before in my life and in a scrooge
nobody expects you to be able to sing
anyway so I never let anybody down I
think people are going to be surprised
when they hear Michael Caine sing I know
Michael was with a thankful heart with
an endless Joy with a growing family
every girl and boy will be nephew and
these to me
[Music]
zombie sort of Rock in the middle that
all of all the Muppets bounce off and if
they come they are funny intrinsically
and uh
and if I was to try and be funny it
wouldn't be funny so the more realistic
I am the funnier it is oh yes absolutely
Michael Kane since he's standing right
over there is doing a wonderful job in
this thing I love you Michael and uh
Rizzo and Gonzo are very silly you know
they're the narrators of the film and
they do lots of foolish things
I play the part of Charles Dickens I'm
glad you asked that because this is the
first serious role that I've ever had
and um usually you know I have to go
home from work uh kind of oh grubby
after jumping into a vat of oatmeal or
something like that but this time I have
a dignified job and uh please go out and
buy tickets it smells so good mother it
does doesn't it Michael Caine is a star
fine Michael Caine is terrific yes but
what about Moi I figured any man who's
got 12 rats and for green frog is a club
is psychotic so I play him as a
psychotic it's the only way to do it
with a Muppets but there's a character
in this called Bean bunny
who's the cutest little character you've
ever seen I mean he's so cute he's
sickening I'll give you a shilling no
I'll give you five Shillings
wow this is the first time that the
Christmas carol story has been done
Justice and I've got my word processor
just over there and as soon as we finish
this I I start to work on Nicholas
Nickleby we've tried to stay very
faithful to the classic Charles Dickens
story they're really the only difference
is there's lots of frogs and pigs and
chickens and rats playing the main parts
I think Charles would have liked it that
way it's all the ways that we sure love
that feel like Christmas
foreign